Український олігарх Віктор Медведчук
в інтерв'ю російському виданню розкритикував
створення Україною зони вільної торгівлі з ЄС.
За останні роки економічні відносини України
Росією дійсно зазнали драматичних змін,
проте товарообіг між обома країнами
почав знижуватися ще у 2012-13 роках –
через рецесію в Україні,
девальвацію гривні після тривалого стримування
та інші структурні вади української економіки.
2014-го та 2015-го
рецесія переросла у обвал.
Перш за все, через анексію Росією Криму
та окупацію територій на Донбасі,
внаслідок чого Україна втратила приблизно 20% економіки.
В результаті: скорочення значної частини експорту
без донбаської промисловості, українські санкції
проти РФ як країни-агресора, зупинка торгівлі
товарами подвійного призначення.
Усе разом це призвело до ще різкішого падіння експорту
українських товарів і послуг до Росії -
2014-го року на 35%,
а 15 -го – ще на 42%
Те ж відбувалося і в імпорті -
з 2014-го різке скорочення:
щороку на 45%, 26%
та 30% відповідно.
Лише у 2017-му ситуація щодо товарообігу з Росією
почала поволі покращуватися.
Що ж до впливу на Україну зони вільної торгівлі з Євросоюзом,
то вона почала діяти тільки з 1-го січня 2016-го року,
коли інфляція вже лютувала, а український ВВП
удвічі скоротився за попередні три роки.
А в повному обсязі Угода про асоціацію
набула чинності тільки з осені 2017-го.
Якщо поглянути на динаміку товарообігу України та ЄС,
то 2015-го року також стався обвал,
після чого почалось поступове, хоч і дуже незначне
зростання: і товарообігу, і загалом української економіки.
За останні роки ЄС став
головним торговельним партнером України.
Минулоріч його частка як у експорті, так і в імпорті
перевищила 40%. Проте торгівля
з Росією, попри війну, також не зникла.
Якщо проаналізувати статистику за окремими країнами,
Росія і надалі залишається провідним
торговельним партнером України.
Заява Віктора Медведчука про падіння
економіки України після розриву відносин з РФ
та створення зони вільної торгівлі з ЄС
відповідає дійсності лише з огляду на певний збіг
цих подій у часі. Разом з тим початок дії ЗВТ з ЄС
поки не міг кардинальним чином
вплинути на підйом чи занепад української економіки.
В цілому ж створення зони вільної торгівлі з ЄС
вже сприяло збільшенню товарообігу, а отже,
в перспективі – підйому української економіки.